AUTHENTIC CHAOSHAN BEEF BALLS
There goes my beef chow fun.
I'm starving.
Aren't these handmade beef balls?
How did you know my name?
I hid myself so well,
-What the...
-yet you recognized me.
I'm just here for handmade beef balls!
That's right, I'm number 2,999
on the Killer Ranking List.
Shou Daliuwan.
I'm starving.
Do you know what it takes to make
the most authentic beef balls?
It will take over ten million
powerful poundings
until all your hair falls off!
How about a recharge with a little oxtail?
You can't even touch your own rump.
Because it's a macho man's misery.
A lot of macho men
will overgrow their muscles
until they develop an area where
they cannot reach with their own hands.
I'll crush you with my ass!
How did you get there?
But your beef balls are pretty delicious.
Though there's no beef in it.
Meddling kid.
MEN, WOMEN